this is a um
less than a minute clip with joe rogan
and
i don't know who she is but she's some
kind of fighter or she was dating a
fighter
and um i'm gonna kind of preface this by
by saying this look um women don't care
about
men's struggles they hang out at the
finish line and they pick the winners
there's a little more r rated version of
that but i try to water this down
for the youtubes so just watch this at
the end of it
she basically closes with he was a great
boyfriend like he was one of the best
but at the end of this episode she dumps
this guy
watch
oh i gotta turn on the yoyo as this guy
is mauling him
he goes like this what do you think i
was thinking
um not good thoughts yeah you didn't
like it
no did it turn you off oh my god so much
whoa i was like dude you're getting
[ __ ] up and you drop you as you're
falling to the canvas you'll still need
to go [ __ ] you
yeah like that so the way he was getting
beaten was [ __ ] with you yeah it
wasn't just that he was getting beaten
i don't care i don't know he was like i
don't care yeah i don't care if he
wasn't dick you're not gonna
yeah like you gotta like take that
take it yeah like you know like a champ
or like a like a fighter
right yeah you can't be like wow
was that the beginning of the end yeah
and he was like a great
boyfriend he was great during the fight
he almost gets knocked all right
he was a great boyfriend he was a great
boyfriend but i still dumped his ass
anyway because he was not the winner
i hung out at the finish line and i
picked a different winner
and i mean she's pretty basic looking i
mean like
i my preference is is feminine women so
take it with a grain of salt when i look
at that i look like
you know like i'm looking at a dude with
long hair and kind of
feminine sort of features on her face
but i don't know that guy
that guy got lucky
you